[Music]
this is a subway pole
a turnstile a seat
[Music]
and this is what's underneath we did see
some geothermal filler species which can
survive on rocks and hot environments
we've also seen staphylococcus epidermis
the most common species was
cute back near acne which is something
that's a normal skin flora bacteria
that is really just being shed off of
our human bodies into the transit system
hello i am christopher mason a professor
of genomics physiology and biophysics at
weill cornell medicine
dr mason and his team started swapping
subway stations in 2013.
we set up an app a tracking system
developed a protocol
and we went out and swabbed every single
subway station in triplicate
across new york city they're looking to
discover and categorize the microbiome
found in city subways the microbiome
is the collection of microorganisms that
are either in
on or all around you and they include
bacteria
viruses fungi parasites really any
little organism
that you can't quite see but that has a
strong a really powerful feature
of mediating health and disease there
are large cities
today where we just don't have a sense
of what they look like or even many
environments
really most of the world's environments
we don't have a microbial or macroscopic
view
of the biology that's theirs so what do
cities actually look like
underneath the microscope
[Music]
we normally swab at least three services
for each city which is consistently
the turnstiles the kiosks and the
benches like for example in new york
city
there is geobacillus thermoleovorans
which is this really
hearty microbe that can survive on rocks
and soil and even be
desiccated or dried out and you know
really takes a lick in and keeps on
ticking and goes on fine like
i think new yorkers you can see that you
know these really hardy microbes have
evolved for the harsh surfaces
of the cities
[Music]
in naples we could actually see a lot of
mediterranean microbes that have already
been found and isolated
in the shores of italy or in greece that
could pop up in the cities
but then we could see you know other
food-related microbes
that would pop up as well so certain
kinds of yeast that are associated even
with cooking pizza and sort of baking
bread
we could sometimes pick up more in
naples than in other cities that was
kind of interesting to see
[Music]
we started sampling before during and
after the 2016 olympics and we could
actually see
you know this change because a million
people swarmed into rio
and started to actually add their
microbiome to the city so we've seen
the burst of new species emerging
as there's a mass increase of humans
coming into a city
and so that disrupted a bit of what the
city looks like at the microbial
perspective
but it also added some diversity to
what's present so i actually think
that the olympics serve not only as a
gathering for sports and human
endeavors but also gives this
interesting you know addition like a
probiotic to a city essentially in a way
tokyo actually has the greatest amount
of novel peptides or new sort of biology
that we've discovered from any of the
cities so far
and why this is is not entirely clear so
there's a chance that
you know some of the novel biology that
we find there is because it's been so
isolated from the rest of the world at
earlier centuries and so
you know that's a hypothesis so we have
to really test that but we're trying to
not really blend
microbial ecology modern genetics
plus history to get a more comprehensive
view of what's happening in the cities
and in their people
tokyo also had a range of new phages or
these viruses that attack bacteria
that we didn't see anywhere else in the
world including some phages
that are specific for c acne or a very
common skin microbe
so you know we can actually see that
these ecosystems on the surface and on
the skin of people
in these cities really have their own
geography and their own
specificity wherever you are in the
world well each city has a unique
microbial footprint
dr mason and his team have identified a
core set of commonalities that cities
share across all the systems we've
analyzed there's actually 31 species of
bacteria
and microbes that are really
consistently found we find them in
ninety seven percent of every swab that
we take
so on the one hand there's this core set
of microbes that includes things like
cute bacner acne
or geothermophilus species humans have
evolved a tolerance
for milk over the past few 10 000 years
and this even is reflected in the subway
some of the species of lactobacillus
are showing up are things that you find
in milk or in dairy products
that we can also see riding on people's
hands and skin
and then show up in the cities we've
seen a good number of extreme files on
the subway
in particular some that can survive in
say the cooling waters of nuclear power
plants like
dinococcus radiodurons as one or other
bacteria that are known to survive on
stone
or survive under high uv light or a lot
of radiations
the subway system and the city surfaces
enrich foreign and probably select for
these hardier microbes that can survive
on rough surfaces full of toxins and
radiation
but at the same time we find that
there's a lot of species that are very
unique to one part of the world that
even give us
a forensic capacity to tell you know
what city did you come from and if you
look at your shoe for example
we could tell with about 90 certainty
where in the world
you came from just from the microbes
that you're carrying with you
[Music]
with subways teeming with bacteria
should commuters start to worry about
the microbes they'll encounter on the
subway
there is some good news in that there is
not an avalanche of pathogens waiting to
greet you at the subway systems a
pathogen is an organism
that is known to cause an infection and
a disease
we've seen no evidence of a wealth of
harmful pathogens or really even that
many opportunistic pathogens
in the city centers or transit systems
but rather we've actually seen it seem
to be a relatively safe environment and
even if we look at things like
antibiotic resistance or
these antimicrobial resistance genes
what you'll find in the subway and
transit systems
is often less than what you'd find in
the soil or even in your own stomach
from the first study my favorite fact
then
and now is actually that about half of
the dna that we sequenced
matched no known species it never been
seen before a new species means that it
has to be at least 20
divergent from anything that's been seen
before meaning if it was a 100-page book
of the genetic code at least 20 pages
would be completely new and never been
seen before
but some but evolution is conservative
so actually a lot of pieces of dna that
we have or bacteria viruses
get recycled and reuse their subway
swabs uncovered over 11 000 new bacteria
and viruses
there was all this unknown life really
under our fingertips
but then other species we could see look
like they were bacteria
that were associated more with rats or
sometimes we'd actually see the rat dna
itself actually you could see cucumber
dna we could see plants and animals
we could see more plant dna closer to
the parks for example so
we could actually see this entire
ecosystem of life
really reflected in the surfaces of the
subway we've also seen
a lot of new crispr arrays these are
basically
the bacterial immune systems that are
defending against other viruses
and they also could serve as a new way
to understand how do the crispr systems
work
can use them for new actually therapies
or drugs or even treatments
crispr is even being used right now for
gene therapies and so finding these new
bacterial functions could potentially
lead the way towards new medicines so
for commuters riding subways around the
world
you might not want to touch the poles
turned styles and seats like you used to
but the microbes underneath our fingers
serve a purpose
i would actually think it's okay to grab
the subway pole if anything the
ecosystem we discovered shows that it is
a very consistent
core microbiome that humans probably
have evolved
with and essentially probably could use
the exposure to that environment so
instead of being afraid of the subway
you could even go in with reckless
abandon
and uh and grab it with some confidence
or at least i do at this point